[Música]
hola bienvenidos a kobe 19 la semana en
américa este es el espacio de france 24
en el que hacemos un resumen de las
principales noticias las más destacadas
relacionadas con la pandemia del cob y
el 19 en nuestro continente
soy santiago lópez gonzález bienvenidos
a continuación los temas que tenemos
preparados para este programa de hoy en
el marco de la conmemoración del día
mundial de la lucha contra el vih/sida
quedó en evidencia que muchos programas
sociales para tratar enfermedades de
alta complejidad quedaron de lado para
destinar más fondos a la lucha contra el
cubil 19 muchas son las personas que han
visto como su salud se deteriora por la
falta de acceso o tratamientos o también
la atención mientras todos los esfuerzos
están destinados a combatir la pandemia
y eeuu sigue siendo el país más afectado
por la pandemia del cob y 19 esta semana
fueron rotos tres récords diferentes en
cuanto a las cifras de contagio de
víctimas mortales y también de
hospitalizados el sistema de salud
comienza a saturarse mientras que los
analistas indican que los meses de enero
y
pueden llegar a ser los más complicados
para el sistema de salud de ese país y
avanzan también las solicitudes de
autorizaciones para las vacunas que han
demostrado tener una alta efectividad
los países han comenzado también a
negociar la compra de los lotes de
vacunas con las farmacéuticas y muchos
países también están avanzando en el
diseño de sus planes de vacunación y
distribución entre la población les
contamos más en unos minutos comenzamos
pero ya lo decíamos en titulares esta
semana el mundo conmemoró el día mundial
de la lucha contra el vih/sida debido al
surgimiento de la pandemia del cob y 19
muchos pacientes han visto cómo han sido
disminuidos los recursos para sus
tratamientos o también han desaparecido
algunos de los programas de asistencia
social para pacientes con vih una
situación que onusida ha advertido sobre
las consecuencias que va a traer en el
mediano plazo
han pasado casi 40 años desde que el vih
o virus de la inmunodeficiencia humana
comenzó a expandirse por el mundo hoy
afecta a más de 48 millones de personas
los primeros pacientes se exponían a una
discriminación extrema de los tres había
una sensación de misterio una sensación
de miedo un claro prejuicio un aumento
una actitud de exclusión definida
ingeniería de tours fue etiquetado
inicialmente como el cáncer gay por ser
frecuente en esa comunidad sólo años más
tarde se supo que éste afectaba a
hombres mujeres y niños por igual los
investigadores franceses françoise barré
sinoussi y luc montagnier lo
identificaron en 1983 el virus que se
propaga por fluidos corporales se
expandió rápidamente por todo el mundo
su combate ha sido lento en 1986 se
lanzó el primer fármaco con eficacia
demostrada para contener el vih y aunque
no fue muy contundente dio lugar al
desarrollo de muchos otros medicamentos
contra la enfermedad
este año el fármaco cavo tegra beer ha
aprobado una mejor eficacia en prevenir
el virus que otros
pero la búsqueda de una vacuna aún está
en curso sin embargo la lucha contra el
sida se ha vuelto más compleja conocida
advierte que el brote mundial de
coronavirus ha interrumpido los
suministros de medicamentos contra esta
enfermedad en todo el mundo
así fitch humanos durante dos meses
estuve usando solo un medicamento se
suponía que debía usar dos y si no uso
los dos es un gran riesgo y puedo
enfermarme en peak risk el impacto de la
pandemia podría causar indirectamente
entre 69 mil y 148 mil muertes
adicionales este año con un impacto
especial en áfrica con 24 millones de
pacientes
y saludamos al doctor claudio santamaría
él es profesor en medicina también es el
rector de la fundación ciencias de la
salud está en la ciudad de buenos aires
muy buenas noches doctor santamaría
gracias por acompañarnos aquí en france
24 y comienzo por preguntarles que no
hay cifras específicas y que apenas
estamos comenzando a evidenciar la
situación pero que es tan preocupante es
esta situación de las personas que
tienen otras enfermedades complejas que
han visto como sus tratamientos o el
suministro de medicamentos su asistencia
ha comenzado a disminuir porque hay que
destinar más fondos para combatir la
pandemia del joven 19
por las noches y la verdad que son
cifras muy preocupantes en argentina y
en otros países por ejemplo ha bajado el
50 por ciento las consultas ha
disminuido el 70 por ciento en las
cirugías y enfermedades como las
oncológicas problemas de salud como la
diabetes los infartos los accidentes
cerebrovasculares no están siendo
atendidos porque todo el personal todos
los hospitales y clínicas están
destinados únicamente al coronavirus y
conseguir un turno y una atención está
demorado y estamos viendo pacientes muy
graves por falta de atención o falta de
medicación
doctor santamaría según varios
organismos internacionales son muy pocos
los países que a la hora de diseñar los
programas para atender la pandemia de
kobe y 19 tuvieron en cuenta estas
enfermedades estos tratamientos para
personas que padecen condiciones que son
de alta complejidad y también son muy
pocos los países que están haciendo
estudios o seguimientos
a las personas que están presentando
complicaciones en enfermedades
diferentes a kobe 19 y por lo tanto no
hay registro no se sabe cuántas personas
se están enfermando de otras
enfermedades
lo que decís es muy cierto no hay
registros argentinas empezó la
cuarentena en marzo y dejó de atender a
otros pacientes en la provincia de
buenos aires- la más importante de
argentina por ejemplo no hay suministro
de medicamentos oncológicos y no hay
ningún tipo de estadística su
seguimiento de atención sólo ahora que
estamos en diciembre desde marzo algunos
hospitales están empezando a atender
algunas otras consultas porque toda la
atención se volcó y muchas personas que
buscan atención no la logran y muchos
otros pacientes tienen miedo de ir a los
hospitales por más que tenemos dos
circuitos diferentes para poder atender
en argentina hemos superado más los 38
mil muertos por coronavirus pero no
tenemos sin fue las ciertas que
demuestren la atención si vemos que los
pacientes llegan al hospital oa los
servicios de salud con patologías muy
avanzadas por falta de prevención y por
falta de tratamiento
doctor explíqueme una una situación
porque estos sistemas de salud sobre
todo aquí en nuestra región en américa
latina'
son sistemas de salud netamente
reactivos responden a la situación que
se les presenta en este caso una
pandemia no son sistemas de salud
preventivos o por lo menos tiene muchas
fallas a la hora de prevenir si lo
comparamos con sistemas de salud de
otros países más avanzados como canadá o
algunos países europeos
lo que decís es muy cierto en nuestras
políticas de salud nuestros gobiernos no
hacen prevención países del primer mundo
a los pacientes le mandan por ejemplo
una alerta para que se hagan una
mamografía una consulta cardiológica y
un seguimiento y les mandan un mail o un
mensaje de texto para ir nosotros solo
atendemos cuando pasa algo y no hay
sistema de prevención la organización
mundial de la salud nos enseña que por
cada dólar que uno invierte en
prevención se ahorran diez en servicios
de salud pero nuestros gobernantes
nuestros gobiernos no hacen prevención
de hecho nuestro ministro de salud en la
argentina creyó que el coronavirus no
iba a venir no compro suficiente este es
y se han desatendido otras enfermedades
en argentina y en la región como el
dengue el chagas las enfermedades de
transmisión sexual las todas las
enfermedades crónicas prevalentes que
han avanzado no hay capacidad de
prevención cuando sería más fácil más
barato prevenir qué
y si algo nos ha enseñado esta pandemia
doctor santamaría es que la prevención
es la clave la prevención ha sido clave
para los ciudadanos para evitar
contagiarse de kobe 19 quedándose en la
casa lavándose las manos usando el
tapabocas y pues tal parece que para
llevar esto a una escala macro sigue
siendo muy complicado para abarcar otras
enfermedades como podemos entonces
revertir esta situación para los
pacientes que están teniendo problemas
para acceder a los medicamentos acceder
a sus tratamientos a sus médicos para
personas que tienen que ir con
periodicidad a alguna asistencia por
parte de los médicos hay alguna forma de
revertirlo o esto ya a futuro va a
empezar a traer las consecuencias
mira la forma de revertir lo sería con
una educación masiva tanto en los medios
de comunicación como en las redes la
diferencia siempre la hace la prevención
lo que cada uno hace suma o resta el
bienestar general en nuestro país y en
nuestras regiones en américa ha fallado
la prevención y la educación los
gobiernos dicen que van a educar y nos
educan eso es la diferencia que tiene
por ejemplo los ciudadanos orientales
que el uso del barbijo las máscaras
faciales el lavado de manos ha hecho la
diferencia si podríamos explicarle a la
gente que se puede salir con barbijo con
distanciamiento con máscaras y que los
hospitales y los servicios de salud
tienen dos circuitos para aquellos que
tienen la enfermedad respiratoria de
aquellos que tienen enfermedades
crónicas
y lo podríamos mostrar cómo es y los
circuitos de atención facilitar como
pedir un turno como hacer telemedicina
sin duda muchos pacientes se acercarían
prevenir unas enfermedades que están
silenciadas y están diezmando la salud
de la población porque hemos puesto el
foco de atención prioritario coronavirus
y nos hemos olvidado de las otras
enfermedades como si dejaran de existir
y entonces cada vez estamos más graves
en salud comunitaria dos aspectos claves
la prevención y la educación el rescate
de toda esta entrevista doctor
santamaría una última pregunta en esta
semana como lo decíamos fue conmemorado
el día internacional de la lucha contra
el vih/sida la información que tuvimos a
la que tuvimos acceso a lo largo de esas
semanas
evidenció que el número de contagios por
vih está aumentando a nivel
internacional en américa latina sobre
todo en los países con mayores problemas
económicos y sociales está aumentando y
hay un problema el subdiagnóstico
también está aumentando esta es una
pandemia no sé si la podemos considerar
una pandemia doctor a la que le estamos
haciendo frente pero que todavía no
hemos ganado la batalla como pensamos
que ya lo estamos haciendo con el kobe
19 y se nos olvida el vih
que sigue ahí y sigue aumentando y
siguen presentándose los casos y sigue
estando latente y sigue siendo un riesgo
claro de hecho hoy lo llamamos sin dem
ya porque es una pandemia con otras
enfermedades y no hemos explicado por
ejemplo como la gente tiene que seguir
cuidándose de laxe ibex de lo que tú
estás comentando que se puede tener la
sexualidad es una cosa esencial para la
vida hay formas no solo con el
preservativo sino que en esta pandemia
pocos han hablado de cómo ejercer la
sexualidad en el medio de la pandemia y
la gente no sabe cómo cuidarse qué
medidas de prevención y cómo consultar y
entonces vamos a tener más enfermedades
de transmisión sexual más h ive y mucha
gente no sabe que hay medidas concretas
para evitar el hb las enfermedades de
prevención y muchos creen que sólo con
los anticonceptivos pueden tener una
sexualidad sin riesgo y por eso la clave
sigue siendo la educación para que todos
nos enfermemos menos y se obtengamos
mejor salud
muchas gracias doctor santamaría por
responder a estas preguntas para la
audiencia de france 24 muchas gracias
por estar con
y pues precisamente en venezuela- los
pacientes con vih enfrentan un escenario
muy adverso a la falta de capacidad del
sistema de salud se suman también las
sanciones internacionales que impiden el
acceso a los medicamentos como los
antirretrovirales y los reactivos para
detectar el vih según varias ongs más de
1000 personas han muerto en venezuela
por las restricciones que han impuesto
en la cuarentena y les impidió retirar
sus tratamientos o asistir a los
hospitales para recibir algún tipo de
tratamiento esta es la situación
jesús rodríguez acaba de salir de
prisión y lo peor de su paso por la
cárcel fue ser una persona con vih
mientras pagó condena su vida corrió
riesgo porque no contó con la atención
médica en los tratamientos necesarios
para controlar la enfermedad si las
personas que estaban en libertad se les
hacía imposible retirar tratamiento por
la situación de trasladarse de un lugar
a otro porque no podían ir entonces
imagínense nosotros la guardia no quería
sacar a ningún privado de libertad para
el traslado del hospital en el hospital
cuando llegamos a ir no nos quisieron
recibir
como jesús más de 100.000 personas con
vih en venezuela no han podido acudir a
las consultas ni han tenido acceso a los
antirretrovirales durante la cuarentena
por kobe 19
datos recolectados por los monitores de
la sociedad civil señalan que entre
enero y octubre de 2020 la principal
causa de la muerte de más de 1000
pacientes fue la falta de tratamiento
una cifra que miembros de ongs temen
puede ser mucho más alta nosotros no
hemos conseguido que cuando vamos a la
'la a los centros públicos de salud nos
niegan la información y las actas de
defunción no reflejan la veracidad de
las muertes entonces son veladas son
disfrazadas se niegan a colocar la
palabra sida en un intento de ganar
espacios para hacer valer el derecho de
la vida de las personas con vih
mauricio gutiérrez seropositivo ha
decidido lanzar su candidatura como
diputado en las próximas elecciones de
la asamblea nacional el sistema público
de salud
dejando morir y hasta el momento la
respuesta de todos los poderes públicos
ha sido ninguna
hablan este de nosotros solamente para
utilizarlos con fines partidistas
proselitistas tenemos como personas
afectadas ocupar espacios de toma de
decisiones se estima que el
desabastecimiento de los
antirretrovirales llega al 65 por ciento
desde el año 2016 el gobierno venezolano
no compra medicamentos ni los reactivos
necesarios para diagnosticar el vih en
venezuela- los organismos
internacionales son quienes se han
encargado de ayudar a este sector
vulnerable de la población que se
encuentra en una situación de
desatención y de discriminación termina
fernández france24 caracas
y cambiamos de tema esta semana tuvo
lugar la cumbre especial de la
organización de naciones unidas en la
que el tema central fue la pandemia del
cob el 19 la recuperación mundial y la
distribución de las vacunas un encuentro
virtual en el que 140 jefes de estado de
gobierno y también ministro de salud
debatieron hicieron balance también
sobre el manejo que le han dado a la
situación en sus respectivos países a
continuación les presentamos algunos
extractos de las intervenciones de
algunos de los representantes de américa
latina' veamos es muy probable que no
logremos cumplir los objetivos de
desarrollo sostenible y quizás hasta
retrocedamos en agudas mientras que ya
habíamos alcanzado la pandemia agravó la
desigualdad en varios aspectos y volvió
a visibilizar las brechas económicas y
tecnológicas de todos los pueblos del
mundo como siempre sucede los más
afectados han sido son y serán los más
vulnerables porque la tecnología es la
base del acceso a telemedicina
teleeducación y teletrabajo estamos
realizando los mayores esfuerzos para
poder adquirir vacunas seguras
clases que sean suministradas de forma
gratuita para aproximadamente 3 millones
de bolivianos
en este contexto esperamos encontrar la
debida comprensión y solidaridad de la
cooperación internacional
particularmente en la ayuda oficial al
desarrollo
es imperativo movilizar las diferentes
fuentes e instrumentos de financiamiento
y condonación de deuda externa el
gobierno de honduras hace un llamado a
la comunidad internacional para que
continúen fortaleciendo el fondo
financiero de la alianza gavi como un
importante mecanismo impulsado por la ms
para garantizar el acceso de las vacunas
contra el código a los países más
vulnerables
honduras reitera su llamado a que se
eliminen las tasas sobre las remesas
familiares durante la actual crisis
honduras ha sido considerado como uno de
los países más vulnerables al cambio
climático en el mundo por los últimos 25
años
y esta fue una semana de récords en eeuu
este país es el más afectado a nivel
mundial registro en espacio de 24 horas
200.000 nuevos contagios 100.000
hospitalizaciones y 2000 personas
perdieron la vida la situación comienza
a agravarse dado que el sistema de salud
también comienza a saturarse en una
nación en donde hay más de 14 millones
de personas contagiadas de kobe 19 y en
donde los expertos afirman que los meses
de enero y febrero de 2021 podrían ser
los más críticos
una nación en cuidado intensivo las
islas de muertos y hospitalizaciones en
eeuu aumentan luego de las festividades
del día de acción de gracias el sistema
sanitario está al borde del colapso en
varios estados algunos expertos indican
que lo peor aún está por venir
es importante que nos re comprometamos
con la mitigación de esta enfermedad
ahora que saldrá una vacuna pero en
realidad diciembre enero y febrero serán
meses duros
yo creo que serán los meses más
difíciles en la historia de la salud
pública de esta nación real des nation
en california la situación ya está a
punto de quiebra la región está cerca de
su capacidad máxima al de las camas de
la uci lo que llevó al gobernador a
anunciar quién pondría órdenes de
quedarse en casa desde las naciones
unidas el secretario general culpó a los
mandatarios que no siguieron las guías
de la organización mundial de la salud
from the starts world organization pro
fight desde el principio la organización
mundial de la salud proveyó información
factual y guías científicas que debieron
ser la base de una respuesta global
coordina
infortunadamente muchas de estas
recomendaciones no fueron seguidas y en
algunas situaciones hubo rechazo de los
hechos e ignoraron la guía cuando los
países van cada uno en su propia
dirección el virus va en todas las
direcciones donde en acción' de varus
goles in britain- action
tras 70 años donaldson retiró a su país
de la organización mundial de la salud
criticando la de estar centrada en china
con más de 14 millones de casos y más de
260 mil muertes legisladores en eeuu
ponen sus esperanzas en una vacuna para
contener el coronavirus pero en un país
donde cerca del 49% afirman no confiar
en una vacuna la batalla para motivar a
vacunar será la próxima
para generar confianza tres ex
presidentes barack obama george bush y
bill clinton informaron que serán
voluntarios para ponérsela
y con la situación en eeuu cada vez más
complicada las autoridades del estado de
nueva york esperan poder contar con
dosis de vacunas suficientes para
inocular a unos 170 miles de personas
inicialmente para finales del mes de
diciembre ante el inicio de estas
jornadas de vacunación queda el
interrogante si las personas
indocumentadas también pueden recibir la
vacuna
si todas las aprobaciones de seguridad y
eficacia se cumplen nueva york que
empezaría su fase de vacunación contra
el nuevo coronavirus el 15 de diciembre
de acuerdo con lo señalado por el
gobernador de este estado estadounidense
en dicho territorio sería aplicado tanto
el antídoto de facer como el de modernas
las autoridades estiman que el primer
envío de facer sería suficiente para
vacunar a 170.000 mayorquín osh y que
posteriormente serían recibidas 40.000
dosis del antídoto creado por moderna
los primeros en recibir el fármaco
serían los integrantes de los equipos
médicos y los empleados de las
residencias de ancianos en medio del
anuncio salieron a flote inquietudes
sobre si los indocumentados serían
vacunados una interrogante sobre la cual
todavía no hay claridad
sabemos que no se puede disuadir a la
población indocumentada a participar
la guía federal hace que los estados
firmen algo llamado acuerdo de
intercambio de datos
el gobierno federal sugiere que
identifiquemos a los destinatarios
mediante el número de seguro social el
número de pasaporte
de identificación de licencia de
conducir
lighting number durante los primeros
meses de la pandemia nueva yor figuró
como el epicentro del brote en el país y
nueve meses después de la detección de
los primeros casos continúa a la cabeza
del listado de estados afectados por la
emergencia en la unión americana al
sumar más de 34.000 de las muertes
reportadas hasta la fecha este miércoles
el número de pacientes hospitalizados
por ccoo el 19 en todo el territorio
estadounidense superó los 100.000 lo que
equivale a casi el doble de la cifra
registrada en la primera ola dentro de
este proceso de desarrollo de una vacuna
la farmacéutica estadounidense moderna
anunció que solicitó la autorización
para comercializar su vacuna que tiene
una eficacia del 90 y 4.1 por ciento
tanto en eeuu como en europa veamos
moderna inició los trámites para que los
entes reguladores de estados unidos y
europa aprueben su vacuna contra el
coronavirus es la segunda empresa
estadounidense en solicitar la
autorización de emergencia para
comercializar su vacuna contra el hobbit
19 huilenses operator anticipamos que el
beneficio de esta vacuna será bastante
significativo y realmente esperamos la
capacidad de implementar esto
inicialmente bajo la autorización de uso
de emergencia y walker en dos de los
30.000 voluntarios que participaron en
los ensayos 196 contrajeron la
enfermedad de los cuales 185 habían
recibido un placebo del total solamente
30 personas desarrollaron casos severos
todos ellos habían recibido un placebo
con estos resultados la compañía indica
que el fármaco ha demostrado una
efectividad del 94 1% para prevenir
contagios y de un 100% para prevenir
casos severos en términos de
preocupaciones de seguridad importantes
amenazas serias a nuestra salud no hemos
visto ninguna preocupación de este tipo
hasta la fecha
sigue los pasos de facer y sus socios
alemanes bayón tec que solicitaron el 21
de noviembre la aprobación de emergencia
en eeuu también los reguladores
británicos evalúan la eficacia y
seguridad de las vacunas de astrazéneca
y the fighter se espera que de ser
aprobada la vacuna de moderna podría
comenzar a administrarse en eeuu a
partir del 21 de diciembre y miren
ustedes un debate sigue estando sobre la
mesa y es sobre el acceso y la
distribución de las diferentes vacunas
en el mundo entero particularmente en
regiones con amplias diferencias
sociales y con deficientes sistemas de
salud como por ejemplo nuestra región
américa latina'
y karatina enfrenta varios desafíos para
acceder a la vacuna con alrededor de 630
millones de habitantes y un vasto
territorio con zonas recónditas y
algunas veces impenetrables no solo el
acceso a dichas regiones es un problema
sino también la conservación de la
inyección ya que la mayoría de las
vacunas debe ser almacenada a bajas
temperaturas lo que supone un problema
para su traslado
uno tiene que ser cuidadoso en la
elección de una vacuna porque es bueno
para su demografía word
las instalaciones disponen en el país
cuánto pueden almacenarla y cómo pueden
distribuirla
méxico tiene por delante uno de los
mayores retos con casi 130 millones de
habitantes es el segundo país más
poblado de latinoamerica para ello su
gobierno ha elaborado un plan para
vacunar a 10 millones de personas cada
mes de forma gratuita para diciembre de
2021 brasil comenzará con la
inmunización del personal sanitario los
adultos mayores e indígenas sin embargo
no es claro cuándo empezará a hacerlo
confía en alcanzar este objetivo en
virtud del acuerdo firmado con la
farmacéutica británica astrazéneca a la
que compró 100 millones de dosis y la
tecnología para producirla en su
territorio sin embargo este acuerdo no
garantiza una total distribución sobre
todo para la población de las zonas más
remotas del país colombia tiene
asegurados 20 millones de dosis para sus
casi 50 millones de habitantes empezarán
por grupos de riesgo y los adultos
mayores
ya han reconocido que la mayoría de la
población no se podrá vacunar hasta el
2022 el gobierno peruano está convencido
de que podrá recibir las dosis
suficientes de la vacuna en el primer
trimestre del 2021 antes de las
elecciones generales de abril
y a pesar de estas millonarias
negociaciones entre las farmacéuticas y
los gobiernos también la distribución y
los planes de vacunación la organización
mundial de la salud fue enfática al
decir que la vacuna no es lo único que
nos va a ayudar a superar la pandemia es
solo un eslabón de una gran cadena que
comienza con el autocuidado
vaccines tuna y con las vacunas no
equivalen a cero casos de kobe de las
vacunas y la vacunación agregarán una
herramienta importante y poderosa al
conjunto de herramientas que tenemos
pero por sí solas no harán todo el
trabajo y por lo tanto tenemos que
agregar las vacunas a una estrategia de
salud pública existente tendremos que
continuar trabajando en el manejo de
nuestro comportamiento personal nuestra
higiene y en muchos casos debemos
reconocer que la vacuna no estará
disponible para todos en los primeros
días del año
y nexter en nuestra sección en redes
veamos otras noticias destacadas de la
semana aquí en kobe 19 la semana en
américa canadá prórroga restricciones a
viajes en frontera con eeuu
así lo anunció el primer ministro de
canadá justin hudo quien indicó que no
retirará pese a las fiestas de navidad y
de año nuevo la prohibición a los viajes
no esenciales a su vecino del sur una
restricción que fue impuesta desde el
pasado mes de marzo antes del inicio de
la pandemia unas 400.000 personas
cruzaban esta frontera a diario
y hablamos hace unos minutos de la
vacuna de la farmacéutica moderna pero
también la dupla facer variante que
pidieron autorización para distribuir su
vacuna en el continente europeo un paso
que abre más esperanzas para la única
forma de ponerle fin a esta pandemia del
joven 19 a esto también hay que añadirle
ese plan en el que está avanzando la
unión europea para adquirir vacunas para
distribuir entre los 27 países que
componen este organismo internacional
coronavirus en uruguay se detectaron 238
nuevos casos una cifra récord de
contagios este país suramericano que era
admirado por su gestión de la pandemia
comienza a registrar récords de contagio
y también un incremento vertiginoso
estos 238 casos que les estamos contando
se trata de la cifra más alta registrada
en uruguay desde que comenzaron los
registros de los primeros casos de kobe
19 el pasado mes de marzo los
departamentos con más casos activos son
artigas canelones cerró largo colonia
durazno maldonado y montevideo
y ante el avance de los movimientos
antivacunas el senado de méxico elevó a
rango de ley la vacunación de los
menores de edad esto para hacer frente a
la creciente cantidad de padres de
familia que rechazan las vacunas y ante
la llegada en el corto plazo de una
posible vacuna contra el kobe 19
omar gomes es quiropráctico tiene cuatro
hijos y a ninguno le han aplicado una
sola vacuna es parte de los padres que
deciden no vacunar a sus niños una
tendencia creciente en el mundo
yo no estoy de acuerdo con la
utilización de las vacunas porque es
querer reemplazar está inmunidad natural
y los métodos naturales de poder
fortalecer nuestro cuerpo para adaptarse
de la forma lo más natural posible como
umar galia tiene sus dudas es madre de
tres y a su tercera hija decidió ya no
ponerle vacunas pues ve más riesgos que
beneficios en la mayoría de ellas me
parece que hay un problema ético y moral
tremendo en querer hacer que las vacunas
sean obligatorias puesto que hay muchos
factores a tomar en cuenta y es que el
senado mexicano aprobó reformas legales
que hacen obligatoria la vacunación si
los padres no cumplen la procuraduría de
protección de niñas niños y adolescentes
podrá tomar acciones detrás de la
iniciativa está ricardo monreal el líder
de la bancada mayoritaria de morena en
la cámara alta y este movimiento anti
vacunas
ha ido avanzando en el mundo
méxico no es la excepción
esto ha provocado que haya rebrotes
de enfermedades que creíamos ya
superadas el infectólogo alejandro
macías quien fuera a estar contra la
pandemia de influenza h1n1 en 2009
respalda la nueva ley la única
enfermedad realmente que hemos
erradicado por la paz ligera moyano y
software que vacunar ya ya no seamos
despreocupar de ella es la viruela ok
todas las demás en cuanto dejemos de
vacunar masivamente vamos a volver el
problema es que no tiene a la gente la
ley aún debe ser ratificada por los
diputados una formalidad que se espera
antes de fin de año
galli a omar y otros padres que
comparten sus argumentos seguirán
evitando las vacunas pues la explicación
de los médicos y la nueva legislación no
los hace cambiar de principio y después
de que la o ms llamará la atención a las
autoridades mexicanas a quienes invitó a
tomarse en serio la pandemia del cobi 19
el país latinoamericano respondió a este
regalo a esta regaño hecho por el
director pedro sá damos fiebre jesus las
autoridades mexicanas indicaron que el
regaño no era para las autoridades
federales sino para los ciudadanos
mexicanos aún así el presidente andrés
manuel lópez obrador
nacido de tractor de la pandemia y sus
peligros esta semana le pidió a los
mexicanos extremar las medidas de
autocuidado de cara a las fiestas de
navidad y año nuevo
hago un nuevo llamado
para que todos actuemos en este mes de
diciembre
con plena responsabilidad
que no
se relaje
la disciplina
que no nos confiemos
si no tenemos nada verdaderamente
importante que hacer
no salgamos a la calle
en el mes de enero comenzarán las
primeras vacunaciones contra el
coronavirus en el estado de san pablo en
brasil el gobernador no quiere esperar a
la puesta en marcha del plan de
vacunación masiva que está previsto
comience en el mes de marzo por las
autoridades federales el estado más
poblado de brasil adquirió por su cuenta
las dosis para inocular a sus habitantes
el primer millón de dosis de la vacuna
de sinovac producida en china ya está en
territorio paulista para el 15 de enero
esperanza tener 40 millones de dosis
esto contrasta con la decisión del
gobierno federal de aguardar las
primeras dosis de la vacuna de oxford
yas transgénica que están estimadas
lleguen entre enero y febrero y comience
el plan de inoculación hasta marzo
esto de nuestro resumen semanal de kobe
19 la semana en américa puede seguir
estas otras noticias también en la
página web france24 puntocom en las
redes sociales y también en la app
descargando la en su dispositivo
nosotros nos encontramos la próxima
semana feliz fin de semana para todos
[Música]